Trascrizione: Angela Guadagno
Revisore: Simona Donda
Mi ritengo molto fortunata,
specialmente al giorno d’oggi,
da poter dire con certezza
di aver avuto un’infanzia bellissima,
un’infanzia molto italiana,
molto mediterranea.
Un’infanzia fatta di ricordi,
di odori, di rumori,
che sono sicura,
essere molto simile anche alle vostre.
L’odore di soffritto
nell’androne del palazzo
che puntualmente si sente ogni giorno
a metà mattinata.
I pomeriggi passati in piazza
a giocare a pallone
con gli amici dopo scuola.
Il rumore delle campane
la domenica mattina,
quando tu vorresti solo dormire
altri 10 minuti.
Sono nata a Roma.
Nata e cresciuta a Roma,
con due genitori provenienti
da due culture molto differenti:
madre americana, che quindi
vedeva la bellezza di Roma in ogni angolo,
e padre italiano che, come me,
dava tutto un po’ per scontato.
Alla fine, qui in Italia siamo abituati
a vedere la bellezza in ogni angolo.
A diciott’anni,
come molte persone di questa età,
decisi che dovevo scappare,
la bellezza di Roma non mi bastava più,
cercavo altro, non sapevo cosa,
ma non era a Roma.
Quindi feci le valigie
e me ne andai a Londra.
Dopo tre anni a Londra, colpo di scena,
non mi piaceva neanche Londra,
quindi rifeci le valigie e tornai a Roma.
Tornata a Roma non avevo
la più pallida idea di cosa volessi fare.
Sapevo due cose:
uno, volevo vivere in Italia
e due, mi piaceva mangiare, tanto.
Cosa potevo fare con queste informazioni?
Ma più che altro che lavoro potevo fare?
Per fortuna arrivò mia madre
che con il suo accento americano mi disse:
“Sophie, ho avuto un’idea,
voglio fare Food tours”.
E io la guardai
e con un accento molto romano
le dissi: “Mamma, ma che ti sei inventata,
cos’è un Food tour?“.
E lei mi spiegò che voleva semplicemente
portare i turisti in giro per l'Italia,
fargli conoscere la cultura italiana
attraverso il cibo
e tutto ciò che
circonda la cultura del cibo in Italia.
L'idea ci stava.
A me sembrava pazza.
D’altro canto non avevo idea
di cosa volessi fare della mia vita
e mi sembrava la possibilità
di un lavoro che includesse anche il cibo,
quindi la possibilità di mangiare.
Quindi decisi di provare
a fare questi Food tour.
E una mattina di nove anni fa
feci il mio primo Food tour
nel rione Monti, il quartiere
dove sono cresciuta a Roma,
e portai un gruppo di americani
al mercato sotto casa,
gli insegnai come si puliscono i carciofi,
gli feci vedere cos’è la cicoria,
loro non sanno cos’è la cicoria.
Poi, li portai al bar sotto casa
e gli insegnai come bere il caffè
in piedi al banco come gli italiani.
Però li portai anche da Roberto,
il giornalaio,
perché pieno di storie del quartiere,
e anche da Umberto, il mio vicino di casa,
che abita a piano
terra e sa tutti i gossip del quartiere.
E anche da un paio di artigiani,
il falegname e il tappezziere,
perché secondo me erano importanti.
Era importante far vedere ai turisti
questi personaggi e le loro storie.
Fanno parte della cultura italiana,
della mia infanzia,
del mio quartiere e dell’Italia.
Il Food tour andò bene,
il gruppo di americani
rimase molto contento
e mi ringraziarono
per avergli fatto vedere un’Italia vera,
di persone, di dialetto, di ricette,
di odori, di caffè, di cicoria.
Era diversa dall’Italia che avevano
sempre visto nei film, nelle serie TV,
nelle riviste, nelle cartoline.
Io ho sempre avuto la passione
per la fotografia
e, sin dal mio primo telefono,
ho sempre filmato le persone intorno a me.
Filmavo Roberto il giornalaio,
Franca che puliva i carciofi al mercato,
Mimmo il pescivendolo a Bari
che sbatteva i polpi e così via.
Però questi filmati li tenevo
nascosti nella galleria del telefono
perché pensavo che i turisti
non volessero vedere quelle cose
ma volessero vedere l’Italia perfetta,
e gli italiani non sono niente di nuovo.
Perché dovrebbero voler
vedere questi video?
Però, la mia vita cambiò quando decisi
di pubblicare i primi video su Instagram.
Instagram ha cambiato un po’ la vita,
ed ebbi due reazioni diverse.
Gli americani
completamente innamorati da questa Italia
che si immaginavano,
ma che non avevano mai realmente visto.
E gli italiani,
divisi a loro volta in due,
una metà molto riconoscente perché...
mi dicevano che gli avevo ricordato
l’Italia della loro infanzia,
dei loro nonni,
quella che pian piano stava sparendo
e che in un mondo che va sempre
più veloce, sempre più frenetico,
non si vede più.
L’altra metà arrabbiata con me.
Arrabbiata perché secondo loro
io facevo vedere un’Italia non reale.
Un’Italia di pigri,
di gente che parla solo in dialetto.
Secondo loro dovevo far vedere un’Italia
fatta di giovani in giacca e cravatta
che ogni mattina vanno in ufficio
e portano avanti il paese,
lo fanno diventare più moderno.
Decisi di ignorare,
anche se ci rimasi un po’ male,
e continuai a pubblicare.
Prima di continuare a parlare vi voglio
far vedere un piccolo videoclip fatto,
così vi fate un’idea vostra
del tipo di contenuto che pubblico.
Ecco, io questi video li trovo bellissimi,
non perché li ho fatti io,
ma perché rappresentano,
per me, al meglio l’Italia,
l’Italia che piace a me, che io amo.
E questa Italia piace anche agli stranieri
che porto in giro, e ne vado fiera.
Sono fiera di far vedere
queste persone e questi video
ai non italiani.
Mi viene in mente un esempio,
e sono le signore che io definisco
le signore delle orecchiette
e si trovano a Bari, la città di mio papà,
precisamente in un vicolo di Bari Vecchia.
Queste signore sono là da tutta la vita
e fanno orecchiette tutto il giorno.
All’inizio, quando erano piccole,
era un modo per aiutare economicamente
la loro famiglia,
per non essere un peso.
Adesso la situazione
si è completamente ribaltata,
perché queste signore delle orecchiette
sono delle star,
sono le star delle orecchiette.
Ci sono milioni di turisti che ogni anno
vanno a Bari, nei vicoli di Bari Vecchia,
a vedere queste signore
che fanno le orecchiette,
si vogliono sedere a tavolino con loro,
imparare a fare le orecchiette,
chiedere la loro storia,
imparare delle ricette.
Ovviamente c’è una difficoltà di lingua,
però si riesce
e si portano a casa
un ricordo secondo me indelebile.
Se lo ricorderanno per sempre.
Hanno avuto un’esperienza
che potevano avere solo in Italia,
solo in quel vicolo.
Se c’è una cosa che ho imparato in tutti
questi anni, 30 anni,
quindi con i ricordi della mia infanzia,
i tre anni passati a Londra
e nove anni di Food tour
in giro per tutta l’Italia,
è che c’è tanta bellezza.
C’è bellezza ma è nelle cose piccole,
non è nelle cose che ci aspettiamo.
Di solito ci passiamo davanti
perché siamo sempre di fretta ormai.
E quindi, vi chiedo domani mattina
per esempio,
quando andate al bar a prendere il caffè,
ascoltate il rumore
delle tazzine che sbattono,
l’odore dei cornetti appena sfornati.
Salutate Sandro, che gioca a carte
fuori al bar, fategli un sorriso.
O anche al signore che vi dice:
“Buongiorno, buona domenica, il solito?”.
Per me questa è la bellezza vera
e la possiamo vedere tutti ogni giorno.
(Applausi)